[Music]
the what podcast which bands this year
that matter looky looky lucky the team's
back we got brad back barry porter brad
steiner lord taco thanks for dressing up
today yeah i put on pants
he's got that 70s uh what is that
aerobics uh
collar thing going did you cut that
yourself 70's aerobics and 80's whatever
did you cut that collar out yourself
when i think of more taco i think of
aerobics
he's a maniac that
guy uh-huh
what have you guys been up to i haven't
seen you forever listen to you
i miss you
you're all moved in i'm glad do you see
do you like the new set i love it i feel
like oprah and i've got a brand new step
to show off i love it i love it yeah i'm
glad you guys what's this all just a
green screen i made this up just like a
taco it's not even really yeah this is a
green screen yeah
how's everything in new york
uh you know it's uh it's getting there
it's been a it's been a tough um
landing
to be uh totally honest the the move was
a little stressful the um getting the
stuff was a little stressful but nothing
will top the stress of
um bringing in two dogs to a city
and one of the dogs not knowing how to
[ __ ] on a leash yeah we had several
discussions
the stress and the worry and the anxiety
of every moment that you're in this
house he's he's gonna he's gonna take it
he's gonna do do you want us and then do
you wanna and then you take him outside
he's just he's got so much add because
he doesn't know what in the world he's
he's sitting it like nothing around him
is is he's a side everything's new he's
a southern dog and you moved him up into
the big city he's a new orlean w thomas
took babe into the big city
yes they did
so that was a little strange but i feel
like uh last weekend we finally got
sort of our feet under us you know we we
live right next to prospect park which
is beautiful beautiful park so we spent
damn near all day getting lost in there
and it finally started to feel
comfortable i'm not going to lie to you
no man i really missed
really really really nice
especially right now with jazz fest
going on and it's crawfish season
oh god seeing my friends post about
crawfish and jazz fest i literally want
to get off the social media just delete
have you not found a crawfish place
there in new york nobody turns out
to ask them for a little crawfish you
want to suck the hell i i think to
i think you could probably go down long
island and find some like chinese
crawfish
but
no no it's not the same in fact i i even
contacted a guy named crawfish he
actually the bonnaroo crawfish guy he
will mail you crawfish boiled or alive
um and so if i wanted to i could get
like 10 pounds of live crawfish and be
like a boil at night on my stove i don't
know
i've got to figure out how to do this
because i am dying nice
well go down the street there to your
your
bar and ask for something something
something
sweet tea and some crawfish yeah let me
know let me know how that goes have you
found a pals replacement yet
oh so of course i do have a funny story
about a bar so
you know everybody if you listen to this
show you know my favorite bar in the
world is a place called pals in my
neighborhood new orleans the greatest
bar i've ever been to in my life
so we take a stroll around our new
neighborhood here in brooklyn and i
found a bar literally a block away from
me
called best friends
best friends
how ironic is
i go from pals to best friends
couldn't find a chums
no
yeah if i ever move again it's a bit of
acquaintance
someone i know
guy i met once just have a hard time
seeing brad guy at a best friend's
i went to okay go to a pals go through
all the best friends go to a pals go to
best friends
okay whatever yeah but it's been growing
okay what about you how's how's dad
how's uh how's taco how's everybody
feeling everybody's great i'm great uh
just got back from shaky knees in
atlanta oh yeah you're shaking shakiness
was fantastic i tell you what if if
ticket sales are down it wasn't evident
at shakiness because it was just as big
this year as it was last year that i
could tell i thought that shake you
actually did well it did great
everything that i heard c3 was really
happy with that yeah
yeah good weather too right good weather
great lineup obviously yeah great lineup
if we could have that weather for bonner
room perfect
and you uh understand you got to play
celebrity for a little bit
three times
somebody some in the crowd
came up to me and said oh you uh you
lord targo from the web podcast said
yeah so
uh
two of them were named john
weird
and then uh then we had aaron who who
was actually on the show back in 2020
before the everything shut down so
nice excited to see them i handed out
stickers
uh i'm out of stickers now by the way
all right oh god
okay
didn't we do i thought we did our head
stickers didn't we do head stickers you
did a few can we do
i haven't ordered anything we need to
start doing those again huh well i'm
waiting on a deal
uh from sticker mule yeah
see very sticker i feel like i got
another one around here somewhere well
now that i have my own head i gotta get
my own yeah but yours would have to take
lessons
yeah it'd be a huge sticker
huge
santa got a bigger head
yeah that that head that brad had made
is a little oversized
well i got the digital version i mean
they can cut a sticker any size
yeah
uh so um so who'd you see a shakiness
what was the standout show uh standout
show for me was god speedy black emperor
it was
absolutely unreal i've never seen it
before
uh
what i didn't even know the words you
just said
got
godspeed you black emperor
is that an anime
they're like a post truck band um they
were i think they were most well known
they had a song on the 28 days later
soundtrack
but of course
i love that movie what
i don't even know what movie that is oh
is that a movie oh that's right you
don't watch a tv show i do i like movies
[Music]
godspeed you black emperor
yeah they've got a i mean it's like a 25
piece band and it's like they've got wow
violins and drums and guitars and you
know a canadian post rock band which
originated montreal in 1994.
uh wow they've been able to go forever
yeah
cool all right all right barry i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you some names of albums
from godspeed you black emperor all
right
uh i'm gonna
i'm gonna give you a name
of the album you tell me if it's a real
godspeed you black emperor name or
totally made up on top of my head okay
okay number one
lift your skinny fists like an antenna
got to be real
that's absolutely real
that is really yes
of course
uh beyond infinites beyond infinity the
cat killed
curiosity
sounds real
that is fake totally fake good for you
all right that's good
how about this
all lights [ __ ] on the hairy amp
drooling
wait that's a taco twitter post
these are taco tweets
[Laughter]
no
i'm sorry that is an actual godspeed you
black emperor album
wow wow what an odd pole this is taco
totally on the the and the best part was
their um their visuals they had they had
a guy with like four projectors in the
back
real film projectors like eight
millimeter and he was running film
strips through them to project just you
know colors and patterns and it was just
bizarre but it was all real i mean this
wasn't like a screen
and at the end he would actually run it
through and slow it down so it would get
heat up by the by the lamps and it would
just straight up burnt so like the end
was just like it just it was crazy
cool wow okay very cool you taught me
something today buddy i i did not see
that coming did not see that coming
um
so the uh the show today is actually uh
one that we've been trying to work on
for you know a few years now because
uh we
have multiple times on the show talked
to ashley capps from ac entertainment
but a lot of people don't know ac
entertainment had a partner when they
started bonnaroo it wasn't just ac
entertainment and um it didn't just
operate by ac entertainment even though
for us
being in chattanooga for all those years
ac entertainment was right up the road
so they were the ones right off the top
of our head and we had close proximity
to it but the partners
that started this whole thing with ac
entertainment was a company called
superfly superfly ran by four guys one
of which is rick farman
and rick farman
one of those guys
that started bonnaroo is our guest today
uh going deep into the history of
bonnaroo and then what he's up to now
and then the future of
uh festival life in general it's going
to be a lengthy one a very lengthy one
yeah he was he gave us a lot of time and
he could have gone another two or three
hours i don't even know i expect him to
we're going to do this again because i
want touch
i know so i know we didn't even scratch
the surface right some of the nerdy
things that we really want to talk about
when it comes to bonus festivals but um
they also produce outside lands and
they've got another project that they're
going to work on too in the next
year so i i really loved it rick is a um
he is a dialed in dude
yeah this guy knows his stuff huh
it it i'm glad we got him and you're
right we ashley uh with ac entertainment
we've had because as you said proximity
we've you know talked to him and jeff
cuellar
uh for i i don't think we you know
avoided superfly we just never um we
didn't know anybody there didn't know
anybody there and yeah this was great it
wasn't until i got to new orleans where
i started hearing names and and the
people that were operating superfly in
fact i i didn't know superfly was was
still
operating because they weren't
necessarily in new orleans anymore just
turns out they they just sprawled across
the country and they're doing uh
incredible work you know still with
outside land so uh that's really really
exciting today i hope that you enjoy
this um it's a big one so you got to uh
pause and and
and take a break you know do it and if
you do pause and take a break please
rate review the show that'd be uh very
helpful all right here we go rick farman
on the what podcast
[Music]
all right y'all perfect
look at that look at that dream boat
looking good
just trying you know trying to match the
energy on the other side here guys i
hear ya where are you these days
where are you set up these days uh i am
in berkeley california
okay
uh because it's weird superfly's kind of
taking on a little bit of a uh
it's a sprawl these days uh where's the
main office now
we we just reopened um
a new office here
uh i mean in new office in new york
about a month month and a half ago
something like that um
so you know uh
obviously with everybody like everybody
we were kind of fully shut down
uh in terms of you know in-person work
and stuff like that um
how big is superfly gotten because the
the isn't the legend there are four guys
and then
when did it become the major entity that
it is now yeah just for starters are we
are we starting yet we can okay just
wanted this this is what we do we just
uh we shoot the ship for a little while
conversation okay cool i i i'm used to
sort of just knowing when we're you know
when we're live when we're going and
when we're done so yeah
barry knows barry knows when he's around
brad everything's yeah
everything's if you see record you
better be on point because
because it'll show up
the reason the reason i ask is because
you know uh not only do we have such a
you know long history with bonnaroo uh
the legend of superfly and then ac
entertainment and then this guy you know
moves to new orleans and i hear all
about the super fly cats and then i uh
two months ago pick up and move to
brooklyn
and you know it seems like it seems like
i'm just following superfly's path
come out to that post here man
it might be next it might be nice um
yes so uh sorry
was your what was your question about
like how big are you mayor yeah how
about how big has before i got in these
days
we're about 100 people today
we do
kind of three different things um we
obviously create you know festivals and
events and experiences that we create
the ip for and like we
the brand and everything
we have
long had a marketing services business
so an agency
that
helps
uh you know different businesses create
meaningful marketing programs
but a lot of that kind of frankly got
born out of
uh work we did at bonnaroo very early on
you know we kind of came up with this
basic ethos of how we work with brand
partners and it was all around if we're
gonna get a brand involved in one of our
experiences
uh there has to be a value for the fan
right as you know
uh at bonnaroo and you know other events
that we created
we don't have your typical stage signage
and presented bys and stage names and
all this kind of stuff
we always felt that if a brand was going
to be
part of one of our experiences then they
needed to
you know have something really tangible
you know that the fans felt was
benefiting them that was adding to the
experience and to the community
um and so we did you know that so well
early on and we onboarded a lot of
brands into that kind of way of thinking
that we ended up um you know kind of
starting a business
you know kind of a complementary
business around helping
brands do stuff like that so we get to
do some fun stuff as an example uh this
year we will be
um you know producing
uh a bunch of different events for
companies that you know bring together
their fans their fandom you know
generally media companies and things
like that that have you know kind of uh
talent and you know uh content that
there's a lot of fandom around so
we love to do we love to bring
communities together and people together
in whatever format we can
well when it was just when it's just the
four of you how old were you when you
really started getting this superfly
thing together
yeah so i'd say the very beginning of
superfly
was um a part-time affair right that was
uh really our first ever event we
actually just celebrated this past
february the 25th anniversary of the
first ever superfly show which was uh
take funk to heaven mardi gras 97
um and uh it was a show at the
contemporary arts center in new orleans
and
um when i say it was at the contemporary
arts center i say that loosely it was in
the parking lot in a warehouse that was
half covered uh so it was not in the
beautiful gorgeous building that is the
contemporary art center it was in their
ramshackled
uh you know parking lot and
um
uh so that was the the you know the
beginning of it was really doing things
like mardi gras jazz fest then we
started to become a regular concert
promoter
and it wasn't until
uh kind of i graduated that it was like
a full-time thing right so that was you
know a few years later 19 really
probably 2000 was when we were kind of
like okay let's see if we can do this
for a living and what i mean by that is
like can we pay our bills right and
literally
we used to joke that we ran the thing as
like a
voiceless organization because we would
pay each other
based on what our expenses were you know
if one guy had a car note and you know
the other guy had a you know student you
know you know student loan
and somebody had you know 200 in rent
the other guy had three hundred dollars
of rent that's how we figured out what
you get paid you just list your expenses
and that's what we're going to cut
checks for just so we can do this
uh i hope nobody included the
girlfriends in some of these countries
oh it was pretty above board
unfortunately we were in new orleans
where it was you know generally
inexpensive to live and we were we were
all
you know um you know doing a little
other things on the side bartending
this is this is where i was going with
this because
um
i uh
because i spent so much time in new
orleans uh the
very good friend of mine howie kaplan uh
reminds me every time i talk about
bonnaroo he
oftentimes reminds me that don't worry
brad the reason bonaroo exists is
because of the howl wolf
because the superfly guys started right
here
well that was certainly one of the
venues
heavily um you know the howlin wolf
tippatinas maple leaf
um and then like a lot of um you know
venues that were sort of off the radar
like uh the riverboat cajun queen
and the masonic auditorium that's at
uh
on the 13th floor of 666 no no sorry
13th floor of 333 st charles avenue
uh we we did some shows up in there um
and then as we kind of started to
graduate a little bit we started to use
some of the theaters um the sanger
theater the orpheum the state palace
um and you know really
you know our jazz fest event and it's
you know relevant right now because the
first weekend of uh jazz fest sorry the
second weekend of jazz fest is is just
kicking off today right now my wife's
down there having fun and
um you know
it um
that event like our night shows during
that and the sort of the energy that was
formed around that really became the
basis for us thinking oh you know what
maybe we can take this energy
and do it in a place where we could have
full control
where you know people could come and
camp and kind of create a much deeper
experience but in a lot of ways it was
similar because we were working with a
lot of the same artists and there was
sort of a community thing that was
starting to happen around these uh night
shows that we were putting that's where
i wanted to go back
when you were talking about it so you
superfly was basically five years old
uh in 2002 when bonnaroo started so
um
and it reminded me we had ken weinstein
on
a couple years ago and he told the story
and i want to get your take on it um it
was basically a phone call to him that
said hey we've got this event we don't
even have a name yet i don't think and
it's gonna happen and what did he say
brad like six months or eight months it
was pretty soon
but then he remembered that moment when
you and i guess the your partners and
ashley
all ended up on the stage uh at on
sunday night looking out
at that ginormous crowd and and thought
uh i think we can do this this this
might be a thing
um first of all did he remember right
and if he did
what was tell that exactly
yeah
can who you know just to uh remind
everybody who's listening in here ken
uh has been his
uh was from the very beginning and he
still is the publicist for uh bonnaroo
uh incredible
guy incredible business
uh partner to us as we were getting this
going a lot of the early
work around how we message you know what
the festival is all about to the you
know industry and the you know all that
kind of stuff ken was
really uh you know
influential in
and um
yeah i met ken because he represented
the band galactic and we
were managing galactic at the right
around the time we were formulating uh
the idea around bonnaroo um and so you
know we just started this friendship
around that and working relationship and
so he was the first person you know i i
thought of when we needed somebody to
help us with the pr messaging
um and yeah that moment that you were
talking about there barry
it's kind of a little embarrassing
almost that we did that you know it's
something none of us would ever
really do again and we didn't uh ever do
after that
but i think there was a tradition
you know in the in the music world of
you know where the promoters and the
producers would sort of you know mc a
little bit bill graham did that famously
right you listen to a lot of you know
old you know grateful dead uh you know
bootlegs or whatever where you know
there's somebody introducing the band
and it's bill graham and then you know
you know quint davis uh who's you know
huge legend in the you know music
festival scene the guy who created jazz
fest you know he does some mc stuff but
i think those guys is like they have a
different level of staturomus or
something
and um you know so we i think felt like
this thing at the end of that first
event to like oh we should go say thank
you and so we all went up on the stage
and did that i think we were all deer in
the headlights we have no business being
up on stage that's that's that's not
what we do we should be in the
background and so
my recollection of that moment was
uh why did we just do that like
and let's never do that again uh
but there also was a celebratory moment
of course the fact that we you know that
actually happened we actually pulled it
off
you know it's you know you can have a
lot of dreams in your life and you can
put a lot of dreams out there
and when some of those things come true
uh it's pretty profound and i i think we
just felt a certain level of gratitude
at that point that we wanted to express
let me follow up real quick um
was it i mean you had just graduated
college you guys all met sort of college
age so you
was it a little bit that uh hubris of
youth that made you think you could put
on an event that size i mean that's
that's
it was pretty
you did it without marketing you did it
without advertising
you you did a camping event in the
middle of tennessee
uh which now you know all of us looking
back now say well yeah it's been a huge
success but at that time i mean i'll be
honest with you even at my paper which
is 64 miles away
we didn't care until the morning of when
we got the word that the traffic was
backed up from you know here to
nashville and then it became an issue
for us
was it just that sort of uh
hubris was it just naivete of youth or
did you you feel like you knew what you
were doing and you knew it would do it
would do well
yeah well two things i'll pick up on
there quickly uh barry you know that
story you just told about you guys not
really kind of paying attention until
then
it wasn't just you i mean even the local
community and even some of the
powers that be that we were dealing with
i think
because it was you know pretty
underground in other words you know like
you said there's no traditional
advertising it sold out right away i
think there was a lot of skepticism in
general locally of whether this was real
or not and i had some great stories
about the aftermath of that that happens
to share some time later but to answer
your question um
you know we you know i often when i'm
advising young entrepreneurs to i like
to do uh from time to time um
often kind of tell them that story about
the fact that like
we didn't know
what we didn't know and that was very
beneficial like i i don't know if i knew
what i knew now would i have ever
started monorail right so i'm not sure
if it was hubris as much as
uh naivety a little bit you know like i
think we you know the atmosphere that
was surrounding you know the formation
of bonnaroo
there were a couple major things that
were going on but first and foremost the
superfly partners we were all going to a
lot of festivals and events and we were
looking really
at the landscape of that stuff just as
much as fans as we were from a business
perspective um you know we'd see these
lineups of all these european festivals
roll out and we're like oh my god like
if we could just go to something like
that that would be so fun and none of us
had the resources or ability to do that
at the time i think one of my partners
maybe had been to a few uh european
festivals
but for the most part you know it wasn't
that accessible to us
we were going to a lot of the smaller
domestic festivals things like high
sierra and telluride bluegrass and there
are a bunch of small festivals in the
northeast that don't exist anymore you
know berkfest being one of them and we
were sort of seeing what
was going on there with the camping
thing and sort of what what there was
forming around that we had our jazz fest
experience so that was sort of like the
soup that we were like okay like there
is this thing going on here
in terms of festivals that we isn't
happening in america but it's a thing
that goes on in other places and you
know could we use the basis of what
we're doing during jazz fest and some of
these things that we're experiencing in
a smaller fashion could we do a mega
version of that here right like that was
a lot of the real initial thing now from
a business side what you had going on
was
this is really at the beginning of the
formulation of what live nation is today
right you had basically the
consolidation of the concert indus of
the festival or excuse me of the concert
industry kind of coming together and i
think at that time um
you know most of the um
you know general
uh industry was not focused on things
like this they were focused on the
amphitheaters they were focused on you
know sort of the things that needed to
come together in order to have that
consolidation happening remember this is
in the wake of woodstock 99 that was you
know obviously you know publicized as a
you know disaster and all that kind of
stuff and so you had this sort of i
think a little bit of like you know
festivals are
not
as
you know interesting for the mainstream
industry
and you had a lot of uh the other parts
of the industry like the agencies and
stuff like that because they were seeing
this consolidation they were encouraging
folks like superfly and ac entertainment
to get together to know each other and
in fact you know one of the ways that
ashley and i first connected uh was
through you know an agent uh tom johnson
is a great friend of all of ours um and
represents a lot of amazing artists he
kind of was one of the facilitators of
like hey you guys should know each other
you know in this sort of consolidated
business the independent guys can have
some strength by coordinating
um and so
um you know that that when we all kind
of got around this you know look our
expectation was not that it was going to
sell out in two weeks was not that we
were going to sell 70 000 tickets the
first year to be clear we were would
have been happy if we just you know got
it done and we got out of it alive and
you know didn't lose money
and you know if we had sold 30 or 40 000
tickets or something like that at that
time i think we would have felt like wow
we did a festival of this big and like
that's great and we got the poster that
was always an important thing to us is
getting you know the poster with all the
names on it the superfly logo and that
kind of stuff like that that was really
our expectation so i i think it was part
um you know just youthful enthusiasm and
naivety and part you know having our
finger on the pulse of kind of where the
fans were at because we were the fans
right we would have been the first
people to buy a bonnaroo ticket i
promise you that if somebody else had
done it we would have been the first in
line you know flag waving ready to go
and so i think a lot of it was really
you know uh coming from that place more
than anything when you started putting
this together
and uh
you i mean as a really first go around
in making a festival what were some of
the challenges what was the biggest
challenge that you ran up against was
the thing that made you say i don't know
if this is gonna work
well there was uh
you know one big uh
factor that we had that gave us a
certain degree
of confidence that we could pull it off
um
and um look the biggest thing that
superfly had done before then was you
know a series of concerts during jazz
fest the biggest venue being you know 3
000 people and no camping or anything
like that
ashley had done a small festival called
i believe mountain oasis
but it was you know a few thousand
people or something so he had a little
bit of a framework for that
but um what we really benefited from
early on
is that um we were able
to tap into the team of people that had
put on the large-scale fish events
um and so you know fish was on their
hiatus at that time
and i had built a relationship with the
fish
team through uh being one of the sort of
facilitators of creating oyster head
because oyster had the band oyster head
with tran estazio les claypool and
stuart copeland was sort of formulated
around one of our uh jazz fest super
jams right that's where the super jam
comes from by the way for you know uh
bonnaroo which you know we can talk
about that if you guys want at some
point but the genesis of that that had
been a concert series very similar to
what happens at bonnaroo now that we had
been doing for many years during jazz
fest and other times a year in new
orleans
and we we got to know you know some of
the people in the fish universe do that
and so when we were initially talking
about this i i started to call a bunch
of them
uh you know starting with john palusca
who was fish's manager at the time and i
think from his perspective you know he
wanted to keep that team together a
little bit he would be you know he
didn't want them to just kind of all go
their separate ways and not continue
that sort of muscle memory of doing
things at this scale and they also i
think they had like a lot of equipment
that they wanted to rent to us so there
was a way you know it's beneficial for
them
and you know to their credit they were
incredibly gracious and generous with
you know advice on hey if you're going
to do it here's how you do it
and so we really from an operational
standpoint um
the fact that we were able to tap into
that crew of people
um you know it it gave us a lot of
confidence of course you know some of
the challenges that unfolded right the
the traffic and you know some of the
logistics i mean when i think back on
the level that we produced the event at
the first year
uh you know i i it's not something i
like i'm that proud about i'm proud that
we did it and that it was safe and that
you know everybody got in and out
eventually and you know was uh uh you
know obviously you know the basis for
what it became
but as as somebody sort of who was
intimately involved in the operations
and the setup of it you know we all knew
that we had a lot uh to improve upon
after that
you did have a second so
that's huge
we did and and we learned a lot in that
one too and we learned a lot in the
third one
which year do you think you finally hit
the uh started getting things right and
organizationally making sense and when
do you think you finally got in the
pocket
well i i had sort of said
to everybody at the beginning
after the first year i would say that i
wanted to be
really good at it after five years
and i wanted to be able to just show up
after 10 years now that that didn't
really happen but closer to reality than
not but i i'd say it took us a good four
or five years you know we we needed to
experience um you know a wider range of
things right and we needed to build a
certain amount of infrastructure like
for instance the exit into the site
right like we needed that we needed to
build more roads we needed to put
drainage into the property we needed to
put in permanent electrical and things
like that and so but i felt like after
five years we we kind of had
a lived enough of it we had had horrible
rain we had had dry seasons before that
caused dust like we we had sort of
experienced most of
what you know the the
variability of elements and and
situations are and i felt after 10 years
we were getting pretty good at it well i
mean
once
there's two things here yeah because
there's i always said that that
torrential rainstorm that third year
really felt like a game changer you know
it was one of those we're going to test
you to the
nth degree and shake you as hard as
possible and we're going to see if
you're going to survive this and then a
couple of years later you had the dust
storm that was just
absolutely awful it really sort of
crafted the the space a little bit
differently but
all of that becomes a lot easier
and you correct me if i'm wrong but a
lot of that comes a lot easier when so
many of the other things
were done right
like for instance the user experience
you keep talking you talked earlier
about not naming the stages and one of
the very first shows that barry and i
ever had was the reason i love bonnaroo
so much is because they always took into
account the user experience and i don't
feel like i'm getting sold to every time
i turn around i've said that since the
beginning i don't feel like they have
their hand in my wallet
that's right and so when you get some of
those basic things that so many
festivals miss
i think the other stuff eventually comes
around and becomes a little bit easier
because you're not worrying about the
the things that you have to hire 15 pr
teams to do
yeah you know
it really relates to what i said earlier
we were the fans
right we knew
that some of those things would not be
you know done in a way that maybe they
were happening in other places wouldn't
work for the bonnaroo
you know demographic that we thought
would want to come to this and and it
because we were the same it was easy to
know right um and um look we have the
advantage of success too at the
beginning right um look art and commerce
are difficult right and it's always hard
to manage
you know how you put something together
that you know you really want to truly
be a valuable
creative experience and a really like
something that people you know really
benefit from
and at the same time you know you're
you're running a business and you've got
you know things that you're responsible
for and look i i don't think this is
that different than what artists have to
deal with right like artists are both a
artistic expression that's why they do
it but this is their livelihood and it's
a business and so
you know
figuring that out is always a challenge
and the more that you can do it
in ways that you put yourself in the
shoes of who you're trying to serve
right and you kind of try and use your
creativity
to
um meet some of the needs that you have
from a business perspective to marry
that
that's where i think you know the basis
of our success around the things you're
talking about has come from is that that
was really our volition all along which
is hey how can we make it feel good if
we were the fan and how can we make it
also feel good and be a win for the
various business elements that we were
serving as well and we still operate
that way to this day on so many levels
like that is guiding principle for what
we do as a business no matter you know
whether it's something we're doing for
ourselves or something we're doing in
service for somebody else
i want to say this
brad and i've said this on the show many
many times but you and and ashley and
and the guys that founded this have
given me personally so many
unbelievable moments
concerts and shows from mccartney to
radiohead i mean just on and on and on
and thank you
but i don't know if you remember you
were also
there
sitting right next to me at one of my
all-time favorite
funniest moments
ever on the farm which was the uh
the oh god
oh god here it comes
i didn't know i know rick was
it was rick sitting right i know rick
was there
yeah i had to bring it up you won't
we were doing the media tour and you and
i were in the golf cart cuellar jeff
cuellar was driving
brad was in the back and we were driving
into where in the woods which was brand
new and we round the corner and they had
moved the mr t giant head
and
one of the great things we love is to
pick on each other and brad hates to be
wrong and so he
he blurts out
hey it's mike tyson
and it's like beat one beat two beat
three and cuellar couldn't stand it
anymore he was so nice because he's
leading the tour right and he finally
says no it's mr t
i don't i don't think was there right
next to me because i remember we were
doing a tour together i had to bring it
up because you're on the show with us
and of course it's an opportunity to
embarrass brad i thought i honestly
thought you were going to say the day
because that was that the same day that
we uh walked to the uh what stage on a
wednesday and i look back and i said
that they moved
i think that was the year before
yeah that's another legendary what
podcast issue okay just because if
you're gonna if you're gonna if you're
gonna if you're gonna bust my chops here
i'm gonna make something very clear that
we have been fighting over for years
rick and you can be the judge and jury
on this one because you're from new
orleans you've driven up and down that
street
is it calliope or calliope
uh
come on i think it's callie my man i'm
streaming my man thank you so much thank
you
yeah
the stage was collaborative i had to
think about that because of that i
wanted to make sure i wasn't getting my
uh things confused but yeah i think it's
pretty pretty sure it's called i'm going
to die on they moved the hill and it's
colliding
we resolved this last episode with kyle
yeah all right
i don't care he's literally the guy that
started it i'm going with him but not a
good guy
rick we i want to talk about what you i
want to
transition and then talk about what you
got going now with superfast but
you'd be as good as anyone what what do
you think
where do you think music festivals are
today 2022 i know we're coming out of an
unprecedented event
uh that sort of hit the pause button
um
and it seems from where we're sitting
that we've got a bunch of festivals
unbelievable number
uh fans have a ton of options
um not just bonnaroo uh but
boutique ones big ones small ones you
know
some of them
in their backyard some of them they have
to
you know travel
a great deal
where do you see the industry right now
um well look i i honestly don't pay a
ton of attention to
sort of the day-to-day machinations of
what's going on out there pretty focused
on the things that we
you know work on um but i think um you
know what you said is the case like
there's a lot more
um you know i would say
diversity of festivals and you know it's
being uh
you know become more niche here and
there right which is something we saw
happening pre
um covid shut down and i think is just
continuing to pick up kind of where it
left off which is interesting to me i'm
not sure i would have expected it that
way but i think um
you know
things being sort of specialized and
focused
whether it's an artist doing it or a you
know
second or third tier city doing
something
you know just starting you know to
become
more and more niche sort of experiences
and
you know we've always looked to
uh europe
as sort of where the future is because
when we first started this
you know that was the case like
everything in europe was you know many
many decades more advanced in terms of
the evolution of the festival market
than it was in america
all the way down to even the equipment
that they had frankly over their tents
and you know the like comparatively to
what was available over here
and um
you know
what you know you had certainly at the
peak and i don't know where it is at now
i haven't followed as much but of the
you know european and particularly uk
festival market
you saw a similar thing where there were
just a lot of you know really niche
orientated events
that kind of spurred off of the bigger
things that were you know
had been around and have been around for
you know decades and i think it's a
natural evolution of things i think from
a consumer standpoint it's probably
really awesome right to have this amount
of options and diversity and choice and
you know accessibility um to these
things um
so you know in many ways like you know
look the creativity being expressed
through this is a real positive
um you know
this has been going on for
eons right people gathering in this
format all the festival whatever you
know it is it's been happening
forever kind of thing nobody invented
this and uh it'll continue to happen and
evolve and morph in ways
that um you know people
driven by you know producers and
people's imaginations
as well as you know sort of what the
market opportunities are and i think
we're just kind of in another you know
kind of interesting evolution of that
with the weirdness of you know coming
back after covet yeah i i hear you when
you say that but do you think that the
big three at least the big three
american festivals you think they're
isn't there any sort of trouble
uh you know i i don't think so no what
i'm seeing out there i mean look first
off you know one of the really nice
things for the
market of that stuff is that you do have
a very big companies that you know
have a lot of resources and a lot of um
you know incentive to
uh continue
these things on at a very high level and
um so i i i think that um you know for
the most part uh you know
that that is a real benefit of the
consolidation of our business right is
is that you you do have
um you know businesses that can
withstand the ebbs and flows of these
things because that is the nature of it
right there you're always going to have
like any kind of business you're going
to have your high points and your low
points and really you know it's it's
having the access to capital and the
ability to withstand those low points
that make things durable and that's very
hard for small business and it's all you
know not easy but but easier
for a large business and i i think we
sometimes lose a site of like you know
why
some of this can be a good thing right
it's easy to sort of maybe
you know look at what could be a
negative around when when businesses
consolidate and things like that well
there there's there's good reasons for
it and sometimes those things are very
beneficial to consumers and so i
wouldn't underplay
you know that in any capacity um
you know i
i think look what i'm seeing with things
that i'm still involved with i'm seeing
really good signs right like we're doing
great with a bunch of our experience
related stuff and
some the remaining festival stuff that
we have and so um i i just think you're
gonna like anything things are gonna
evolve and change and be lumpy a bit and
you know that that's the nature of
business that's the nature of marketing
and the thing that you're involved in
now that's
sort of in the same vein of highly
curated specialized uh event
operations right
is that what superfast was sort of born
from with that idea
well superfest is a new thing and happy
to talk about that the other thing that
you know we still produce these days is
outside lands the festival in san
francisco's golden gate how is it that
all these that we've never been outside
lance i mean it is one of the great ones
in the country and i've never been
uh especially knowing what we do
uh well i'm only going to blame you for
that yeah
thanks well now you're getting the hang
of the show rick
you know
it didn't take long brad
you know
so um no man i mean you're crazy
you've been to new orleans jazz fest
well here's this is a very sore subject
in this house uh we moved to new orleans
two days after katrina i mean two days
after mardi gras two years three years
ago and then two weeks before a global
pandemic sent us all to the house and we
bought we didn't buy we we rented a
house inside of the jazz fest
neighborhood we were on ursuline and we
got that house specifically so we could
walk to jazz fest i get a job that
brings me to brooklyn in the city a week
before jazz fest i'm looking forward
jazz fest
um and you've never
missed three jazz fest yes
but you've never been even prior no we
got one mardi gras and then we got uh
zero jazz fest well i love mardi gras by
the way i'm a huge mardi gras fan and
personally i'm i'm more interested in
going to mardi gras than just it was one
of the great i love josh too i i it's
just for my personal things i'm
interested in these days it's it's
the great two weeks of my life it was
legit two weeks ago
very under under appreciated event
nationally i think people have a warped
perception of what mardi gras exactly i
mean most people think thinks it's it's
boobs in the french quarter and um yeah
you don't see any of that none of that
exists
yeah so
very deep cultural event with many many
layers and flavors by the way not to get
off the tangent here but the best part
of uh mardi gras for me was uh skull and
bones waking up in mardi gras day uh
which is very i can't tell you if you if
you don't like doing things afternoon uh
you wake up at five o'clock in the
morning and you go to treme which is the
oldest african-american neighborhood in
the country and you watch this
crew come out in this in full outfits
right and the whole point of skull and
bones is to walk around the neighborhood
and beat on the doors and wake people up
on mardi gras day uh then they they
chant through the streets they've got an
incredible uh drum circle they create it
it's one of the most magical moments of
my life
is very cool
um
super fast so where were we
uh
so
well we were at outside land still for
so you got to make it outside lands you
maybe go to jazz fest first uh although
you know we have outside lands in august
this year you guys are all invited come
on out and come check it out with us
you'll you'll it will feel very
different and very familiar at the same
time right you will notice the style
that we produce at and how things are
done and sort of the the some of the
look and feel the lineup's incredible
who who is who's mainly are you guys
booking it yourself
uh most of the booking for outside lands
uh really happens with another planet
our partner uh on that festival so kind
of like we partnered with ashley at
bonnaroo we partnered with the
preeminent local
northern california promoter another
planet they were sort of the
you know uh principals uh behind bill
graham presents after bill passed away
um they for a time ran that business and
then kind of went off on their own and
started you know what is another planet
and they're awesome people they're you
know really close friends they operate
all the awesome venues here in the bay
area like the fox theater and the greek
theater and the bill graham civic and
all that kind of stuff and so because
they're so
good at and so entrenched in
the regular day-to-day booking of talent
through this region uh they really
handle that and like you said brad i
mean they do an incredible job like it's
it's it's hard it's really hard to book
a festival you know people
you know
you know some of the insight like you
know to share on that just quickly is
that like
people are always questioning why don't
you have this band or that banner why is
this man at the same time and you know
let me tell you it's not for reasons
because of the way the person booking
the festival wants it to be right if the
festive if they could just wave a magic
wand it would all be perfect but that's
not how it works you got a lot of
uh you know masters to serve there all
the different artists their
representations their schedules
you know their production like it's a
it's a jigsaw puzzle on top of a jigsaw
puzzle on top of a jigsaw puzzle i mean
it really difficult job so the people
that do that
um you know uh that do it really well
are uh
and to still do it mostly independently
too thank you
we're we're very fortunate to be in
business with those folks
because you said jigsaws i heard
somebody describe it as putting a jigsaw
puzzle together without a picture or
shapes
[Laughter]
that's pretty good yeah it's probably
pretty good it's funny and and having to
you know negotiate with uh you know some
some uh pretty
you know strong-willed people on the
other side of the coin so
um you know so that that's that come out
to outside lands though it's really it
it is
you know what what really is for us for
the way that i kind of for our history
interpret it it's in between jazz fest
and bonnaroo it it's taking the best of
both right you have sort of the
advantages of a city festival
um
in terms of the comforts that you get
along with that and that format
um and then you know you have
like this incredible
uh bay area culture to play with and
then you have the creativity of you know
our our team and what we do there and
um you know it's it's it really is a
special especially this is what year is
this for outside lands
uh i think it's 14. it's been a minute
hasn't it that's right
yeah yeah we got it pretty dialed in i
mean it's just i mean what a fantastic
festival congratulations the um so what
tell me about superfest i i read a
little bit about this uh it sounds
exactly like you were talking about them
it sounds exactly like you were
describing
where the industry where festivals where
live experiences are going in general
yeah although with a big uh
differentiation uh
in
how we're doing it and what the idea of
it is is
it's almost sort of we're kind of trying
to reverse engineer how one creates a
festival okay so typically
you know somebody like us
comes up with the idea
and figures out all the p's and q's
where is it's gonna be
who's gonna be performing what you're
going to spend on it like all of those
things right
and then you put it out to a community
of you know you put it out in the world
and you hope that people want to attend
it and you hope
in like the case of bonnaroo that some
sort of like you know you know
foundational community forms around that
right like that's what you're hoping to
achieve when you do something like this
um
and
what we're trying to do is super fast is
kind of the opposite we're kind of
trying to start with the community
right this is the idea is like let's
assemble
a bunch of people
who
are have a passion
for
festivals and experiences and music and
culture and art and see if we can
create something together
that um you know in a way sort of is a
self-fulfilling prophecy right that that
because we're doing it with the
community we are going to know exactly
what to build as much as you can
before we do all of that work that i
just mentioned before
um and the reason that we're doing this
now and the what what is sort of helping
to pave the way and facilitate this
is
um a lot of the things that have arisen
in the sort of broader world of crypto
currencies and
you know web 3 and
um you know
that whole sort of world of
nfts and things like that i know i
probably said a bunch of words that some
people know what i'm talking about and a
lot of people probably don't which is
totally understandable
um and so i i can walk you through it a
little bit but
the way to really process it quickly
right is that
what we're really trying to create is
almost like a membership model right
where
people are
joining sort of this organization this
ex this thing right is super fast with
the intention of being a member right
and the way we're really kind of
positioning it is like
where people are really co-founders
right we're inviting a community to help
us create this thing from the ground up
and we're doing that in a way that is
sort of comports with how communities
are being created
uh around the crypto blockchain nft sort
of universe
web 3 universe of things
and you know the way to think about a
lot of that is really
an evolution of how people are
communicating and coming together
to create
communities right like a lot of what
precedes this is all the communities
that have you know
um
you know been created because of the
internet and because of digital
communication and social media and
things like this and what's been plugged
into this is a way of uh really creating
you know sort of value and ownership and
digital ownership that applies to
um people coming together to support or
participate in something collectively
and so we're hoping that we become great
facilitators right we become the ones
the professionals who know how to do
this but can help a group of people
coming together with that volition of
creating something new and interesting
and progressive and like i said before
you know like being done by the fans in
the same way when we started bonnaroo we
were the fans well you know we're not as
much anymore right i'm a guy in my mid
40s with you know
family and kids and you know i'm not out
there you know
as much as you know understanding and
yeah we have amazing people that work
for us that do but when you really bring
together
the fans to build something you know um
we think we can do something great and i
i'll
give you one other reference point to
for you guys one is mardi gras right
like think about how mardi gras is
created by the people that are going to
mardi gras yeah you have a little bit of
your floats and your but those are the
same thing those crews that put on the
big mardi gras parades they're just
collectives of people right who are
pulling their resources together and
paying their dues into those crews so
you can have an endymion parade or an
orpheus parade or whatever it may be
right um the other reference point is
burning man which has been hugely
influential to me you know i started
going um you know midway kind of into
bonnaroo producing bonnaroo and and
frankly a lot of the things that sort of
became more of the community of elements
of bonnaroo were because we were
inspired by going to burning man and at
burning man most of the content there is
created by the audience
it is created by people collectively
coming together and saying i want to
build this really cool thing and the
reason i want to do it is i want other
people to have fun with it i want it to
have a positive impact on other people
and that's what we're trying to do
exactly what you're saying and
especially the mardi gras reference
makes a lot of sense but you're
obviously creating something that's not
linear so this is a hard question to
answer but how far along the process do
you think that you are
oh we're early we're really early right
now yeah yeah yeah you know we are just
forming the community you know we've got
right now about you know 3 000 fairly
active people
in our discord server discord is a
platform that many of the crypto
projects and web 3 projects sort of use
as their
sort of you know social communication
platform
um and
you know it's active we did this thing
yesterday called a super jam not not
surprisingly where we
we opened it up to the community to have
a creative
uh brainstorm on things around what do
we want to create what kind of format do
we want this experience to be is it a
traditional thing with bands on stages
or is it something a little different
than that right and so
um we had an amazing dialogue you
actually can go in there and listen to
it it was like incredible listening to
people who have been inspired by some of
the things that we've done say hey i
wish we could do this at a festival i
wish we could think about it you doing
this on a regular basis
so yeah
yeah
so uh go to the twitter handle first
it's at superfast and the superfast is
spelled with a three for the e so it's
s-u-p-e-r
s-t that's at s-u-p-e-r
f
number three
s-t right that that twitter feed is sort
of the the you know sort of starting
point for communication from there you
can click on the link to get into the
discord server
and
um
you know that will um
you know
uh unlock that whole social experience
that i just talked about being able you
know to sort of interact with the whole
community
um and
what what so yeah go go spend some time
in there check it out you know there'll
be the way these things work is there
will be a moment within you know
sometime likely in june
where we'll do what's called a mint and
a mint is where people essentially buy
their membership right
best way to think about it and so you
know we're we're going to be issuing
essentially 3 000
uh founder
uh
you know membership tokens right the
ability to sort of buy that membership
the initial group will be 3 000 people
now as we sort of go and figure out what
we're gonna do and figure out how to you
know uh marshall the resources to do
that we'll we'll do
you know other future mints that will
give people access to the events and
things like that but that's the starting
place of how we're doing it and um very
different way of doing things
too early do you not want to try to put
a a limit a boundary on
okay
yeah it's really too early and you know
the answer to many of these things
not everything right there are things
like safety and security and operational
plans and you know
uh
business modeling and budgeting that you
know will be the domain of superfly
right but most of the things are going
to be
around that are going to feed off of
what the community wants
this is not for me to be making the
decision as a producer this is me to be
facilitating what the community wants
and so some things will be
conversational right brainstorms and
just getting general input some things
will be a vote right and each each uh
super pass holder will have one vote you
buy ten super superpowers you could have
10 votes but essentially we are going to
put up a whole bunch of things for the
community to decide on or
give us guidance on right and that that
is
kind of it's new we're this is an
experiment
it could be
you know a disaster it could be amazing
in terms of when i say a disaster i mean
like hey maybe nobody will care right
nobody will be interested and it won't
be anything um in terms of the actual
producing of the experience of course
you guys know how we do it and we would
never do something that wasn't going to
be safe and you know run in a way that
was you know appropriate for you know
taking care of people as they come to
something that we create that that
that's you know
25 years of history of of uh of
delivering that we always will but
um you know
what we don't this has never been done
before this has literally never been
done before nobody has ever started a
festival
this way it's the first time anybody has
taken this surprise
and
um we think it's a
really cool way to be thinking about
things right now and to you know to your
point earlier barry like
you know frankly i don't have a ton of
interest in just going to build another
you know traditional festival i'd never
say never in the right situation the
right moment if i feel we can do
something that you know adds value to
the world then fantastic but
the idea of doing it this way
this really lights me up this is
exciting to me to take our skill set
experience our history and apply it to
this new mode of doing things and to do
it in a way that you know frankly um you
know kind of hits on some of the things
that as i mentioned you know the way
that that you know uh some of these
other experiences are produced that are
affecting me in my life very positively
if we can create something that has a
similar dynamic fascinating given what
we've talked about for the last hour
because you're combining that
i won't call it naivete because you
don't have naivete but you're trying to
it sounds to me like capture that sense
of we don't know what's going to happen
and that's what's exciting
coupled with we do kind of know what's
going to happen because we have 22 years
worth of
of doing this so i would think part of
the challenge is for you you with your
experience to get out of the way
basically you know you don't want to be
the guy at the table saying that won't
work and here's why you know you want to
be the guy saying
that's a crazy idea let's figure out how
to make it work let's do it let's give
it a try
let's make it work
well you
yeah you're right i mean barry you know
it's a really astute uh perspective
you're having and i'm gonna have to do
my best to do that because you know my
role uh for a long time in our
organization was
to be
the pump the brakes guy a little bit you
know and be the hey yeah
that's not that practical
and so we actually had a conversation
about this this morning on this project
that like
you know one of the things that i found
interesting when we did the super jam
yesterday is that a bunch of the people
who were throwing out ideas when i would
was giving some feedback
they were like oh my god this is so
great to have a professional who knows
what they're talking about and has done
this to help inform us of what really
can happen and what maybe you know
shouldn't happen right and so
you know that's a responsibility i'm
going to take really seriously on this
is not to be a dream killer
right because it's easy to be that right
and at the same time you know be a
responsible practical steward
of uh trying to enable this community to
build something that really can happen
right and that that is the that's the
goal that's the volition we need to
create something that really represents
um the wishes of this community in a way
that uh is safe and you know fiscally
sound and all that kind of stuff and you
know that that's a cool challenge uh to
do it's a cool challenge a hard
challenge to do when you're just dealing
with a couple business partners it's a
whole nother ball game when you're
dealing with thousands of people and
um but i i feel like the people that are
going to be attracted to this are going
to have the right volition of of doing
something great and doing it in the
proper way and following you know the
guidance that we have in terms of the
things that um you know really matter
and so it's it's it's already been a
pleasure
literally at the very beginning of this
um so i i you know uh invite everybody
to come check it out a little bit um
this is
not to be meant to be you know a st uh
the re you know the a
um
replacement for the kind of festival
experiences that people have right like
you know i think if you go to bonnaroo
you'd want to go to this as well maybe
not instead of it i i don't think so
right this is going to be a very
different experience you know than than
what you would get with something like
bonnaroo and um
you know one of the things i i want to
just say i i gotta probably run in a few
minutes and it's been delightful talking
to you but
one thing i wanted to make sure i got in
before we ended here is that i am so
excited to go myself to bonnaroo this
year
i i i am beside myself to be honest that
i can now go experience bonnaroo is it
because you haven't done it as a fan
before or is it are there certain things
about the the lineup the the festival
that you're really excited about no not
because i've never done it as a fan you
know i mean i my bonnaroo experience has
been
working for me
i got extra room on the bus
too much
potentially negative karma that if i
camped at bonnaroo i am confident that
everything bad would happen to me
uh
no i i'm i'm going to stay in a you know
rv type of situation because that's what
i'm used to at bonnaroo and at this
point in my life that that's the comfort
that i need um but um i um you know my
bonner experience although don't get me
wrong i've had a lot of fun moments out
there and i've experienced the festival
you know in a really enjoyable way
but you know i was always had a lot of
responsibility you know whether it was
to the business part uh whether it was
to having lots of friends and family and
business people that i'm hosting there
and like a whole it was you know major
major part of our you know livelihood
and business life
the whole way through and so now that i
get to just come i'm going with my
brother a bunch of our friends my wife
you know we're just gonna go have a
blast i just the idea of being at
bonnaroo and not having to worry about
where i am at a particular time or who i
have to go meet with or what thing i
have to go do or i like and i want to do
all this this stuff that like my friends
have been doing for years like one day i
want to go get breakfast at waffle house
i've never done that
you know i've never done a lot of the
things out there that
um
did you ever in any of the days did you
ever go to the christmas barn late at
night did you go to any of the late
night parties on ga yeah
okay
yeah a little bit
yes no i i've experienced it all in that
regard but always with like
some you know
not in a full-blown way right i've
always had to sort of you know just be
you know in the moment and
room you know
this is this this was work right like i
have not been able to ever fully let
loose
i love the idea that rick's idea of
letting loose is going to waffle house
in the morning
that is
pretty good
wow i get it that's part of it but it's
just
it's just having responsibility frankly
you know and that that that's like you
know i i don't know
like the only analogy i can give it's
not a good one but like things like this
you care so much about them they're
they're almost like a child right like
you care about it so much and you have
such a responsibility to it
you know that like you know
you know what
some ways the way i feel now is that
like our our you know child is an adult
and it's able to fully care for itself
and i can still you know experience my
child right as i know many of my friends
who have adult children who are like now
i can go hang out with my adult child
as a peer as a friend you know and i i
think that's what bonnaroo is going to
be like for me right which is like it'll
still always be something that we
have feel you know very connected to in
the creation of but i don't have the
responsibility of being but you get to
be a friend again for the first time in
a long time you get to be a fan you're
going to bring a notepad
yeah you're right taking notes just to
share okay all right oh good oh i'm just
yeah you don't have to do it
about anything to that garbage can
[Laughter]
thank you so much for the time it's it's
tremendous and um you know what you and
ashley did
i said it to ashley capps and barry
makes fun of me but it really did change
lives you affected so many lives and you
damn near saved uh the music industry um
so you know thank you for that thank you
for your time i want to hopefully at
some point pull you back into this
ridiculous hemisphere uh
maybe before bonnaroo and tell some
bonus stories and just go deep into you
know your
your well of bondroom information i'd
love to hear uh some perspective from
you on that and then maybe after
bonnaroo
hearing about how it was as a fan
well i i i appreciate you guys love what
you do love that you're propagating the
bonnaroo culture and vibe and uh you
know for as long as i'm here i'm gonna
be doing that you know um i i care
deeply about the festival and the
community around it and i i
um you know want to continue to do
everything i can to push that forward
and so thanks for for what you guys do
and for your time and uh you know uh
happy to to to
the ship with y'all uh whenever also
what are you playing right now what's on
the turntable back there what's the last
thing you play
uh a lot of things been broken for
a while much to my wife sigrin every
time she comes in here she kind of gives
me a little like the record players got
killed
already
because she loves that most of these
records frankly are her i i'm uh
i'm a digital guy living individual
world i joke with her she's an analog
girl living in a digital world and so
she gets frustrated that she can't just
put something on and press a button
um but um no look there's so much good
music out there these days man well you
got my favorite band in the world right
now at the outside land that's wet leg
uh you know oh they're great
absolutely let's check that out thank
you rick thank you so much
all right there you go rick farman i'm
going to say part one
of our conversation because i feel like
we've got multiple more to go with him i
hope so i hope so because yeah you
you know he has some stories the funny
stuff the behind the scenes stuff the
i mean you asked him about you know what
are the what were their challenges i
felt like we could have
we could
yeah we could have gone an hour on that
kind of stuff i mean i want to talk to
him just about
the rainstorm of the third year because
i can't imagine how that changed
everything
i've told this story 100 times
when i woke up that morning after the
major rainstorm and we were two feet
sunken into the ground and a random kid
with a atv was pulling cars out of the
mud i mean it was an absolute [ __ ] show
and you know if i was them i would look
around like i don't know if i want to do
this
yeah the and the right thing for me
i remember going to bed that night
watching the lightning thinking i'm
going to die because i'm in a pup tent
you know i'm not going to survive this
but also the dust storm yep two years
later i remember walking out into the
center room and the parade and thinking
oh they they're putting off smoke bombs
these people spare no expense and then i
realized it was dust and then i thought
i've got legionnaires disease i'm gonna
die
i didn't know how much of a
hypochondriac you were very i was
worried i'm breathing i couldn't see you
know my hand in front of you that this
is this is people's
funk this is not good so
yeah they've overcome a lot of things
and uh
you know to hear him talk about they
didn't expect 70 000 people that first
year
imagine that you know it's the old you
throw a party and invite 10 people and
100 show up you know
kind of a big deal so
it was great it was great talking to him
yeah it's uh there's a lot of area area
to cover that's for sure guys i miss you
and i hope i see you again soon
you cut off my shakiness oh is there
more shakiness
well
yeah that's fine i'll just i'll throw
out a shout out to uh the dashboard mom
she wanted me to mention her are you at
a dashboard mom
yeah oh man what else did i miss on
shaking his talk what else
i don't know you cut me off so you know
i'm sorry i was trying to get to rick
we got a long show
we're getting a long show yeah
all right hold on hold on hold that
conversation about excuse me hold that
conversation by shaking these and we'll
talk about it next time do you need to
hold up a picture or
tell her any specific you got a
any any messy you know is that it
she asked for a shout out so i had to
throw it in well there you go well i
want to hear more about shaking these
i'm sorry i didn't mean to cut you off
so put a pin in that and we'll come back
to it next week okay
okay because hopefully next time it
turns out we need content for next week
and i got nothing well hopefully next
time we'll have the schedule it should
be coming out pretty soon i've asked and
not gotten any answers so yeah the the
times and also do you think it would
come out is it normally in the middle of
may
i mean yes it is yeah because it's two
three seven around the corner okay all
right yeah so we got schedule and
shakiness talk for next week put that in
the books kids
all right all right talk to you next
week
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network